Peggy 18 my favorite part of murdering
is the motor part saints row has been
such a consistent part of my life for
the last four years say what you want
about the Saints but at least they let
you play as a woman woohoo and Kinsey
just speaks the truth she tells it as it
is and she's like either like it or you
don't but I really don't give a [ __ ]
what you think about me I'm coming too
are you kidding me how do you plan to
come back yeah I try not to sweat it's
my birthday
fine people who play an instrument you
know are able to create different sounds
and different melodies from that
instrument for those people who can use
their voices in such a way to create
characters different animals it's a
pretty unique skill I like this kind of
lucky let me get Sleeping Beauty where
there's like the storybook it opens up
and I say illuminated texts and the
storybook pages and you're seeing the
material for the first time they can't
let this stuff out of the room because
it is top secret they'll tell you a
little bit about the game they'll show
you some things to inspire you and then
the inspiration is kind of
improvisational though
besides this what are the other two down
the other two if two of them are
basically the same they're kind of like
um demon gladiators you know shirtless
armors have tough brutish guys like this
yeah like this I've got you I fight you
there's just there's different ways to
make a low sound you can make it with
your throat down there which doesn't use
my voice really it just uses flesh that
flaps around my throat and you can also
modify it with pinching off the nose
with the shapes we advanced shuttle slow
deep with darkness Jack from all sides I
can kind of affect it like that holy
[ __ ] off I have never seen anything like
that in my life
[ __ ] me running dude it's amazing I'm
not a badass but I play one in games and
in cartoons sometimes exertions pain
sounds combat sounds most games
it's very cathartic I enjoy it but it's
a very interesting method to learn you
have to get your body into it because
you can hear all that oh crap
we have fire screams those are the best
if so much fun
Blackbeard fire scream for the love of
God it's a good Adama no work out of the
end of it it's the new p90x routine
should be good what's fun about playing
multiple characters is for one thing as
an actor you get to stretch your range
you really get to inhabit this world
it sometimes happens that multi music
playing end up in the same scene
together what was also an interesting
challenge is trying to make it so the
characters are distinct and sound
different up where the player can't tell
a thing that time might come to pay old
Cupid for Dean and Kiki fall in line we
will take them now some base so you can
burn for eternity
like you just never know what's gonna be
handed to you you don't really think
about when you're playing a video game
but as you get a chance to watch these
performers work you can't help but it
admire what they're able to do you know
they keep pumping out saints row and as
long as they do I want to be a part of
it
[Music]